space hotels with pools gyms bars
and gourmet food have been one of the
most common fantasies
shown in sci-fi space movies given that
only 553 people have ever reached low
earth orbit
and only 24 people have gone past low
it seems like space hotels won't be a
thing for decades if not centuries
so you might be surprised to hear that
people may be staying in space hotels
by the end of next year if you think
about it
we technically already have a space
hotel which is the iss
dozens of astronauts visit and stay on
the iss for extended periods of time
every single year according to google
though a hotel
is an establishment providing
accommodations meals and other services
for travelers and tourists
since iss astronauts are employees and
crew members as opposed to travelers or
tourists
we can't technically say that the iss is
a space hotel right now
it should be noted though that seven
private citizens have traveled to the
iss throughout history
meaning that the iss has been a space
hotel in the past
surprisingly nasa actually wants to make
this a regular occurrence
as they announced that they were opening
up the iss for private visitors in june
of 2019.
nasa has been conducting experiments and
research on the iss for two decades at
this point
they claim that there's still plenty of
research to be done in low earth orbit
but at the same time they're looking to
move on to bigger things like returning
to the moon
and building a lunar base so opening up
the iss for commercial tourism
is unfortunately the early stages of
nasa phasing out the iss
nonetheless it does make for an
extremely cool tourist destination
in the meantime nasa revealed that they
would be allowing up to four private
astronauts inside the station at a time
and they would be charging just 35 000
per day per visiting spacecraft
this means that you can send as many
people as you can fit into a single
rocket for the same daily price
of 35 000 if you were to send a starship
filled with 100 passengers
each passenger would only be paying 350
per day
given that only four private astronauts
are allowed inside the space station at
any given time though
it would be best to travel with a group
of less than 10 people each visiting
group will be allowed to stay at iss for
up to 30 days
and nasa will accept two groups of
visitors every single year
nasa was originally aiming to have
private astronauts on board by the end
of 2020
but clearly that didn't happen the
problem is that though the price to rent
out the iss
is actually extremely cheap it's
extremely difficult to source a rocket
and thunder rocket launch
a startup called axiom space is working
on accomplishing this though
in march of 2020 axiom was actually able
to book a crew dragon launch with spacex
that was supposed to happen
at the end of 2021 since then it has
been pushed back to the start of 2022
but fortunately there's no signs of the
trip being cancelled or anything like
that
the plan is to send three tourists on a
10-day trip to the iss
two days will be spent in transit but
the tourists will have a full eight days
onboard the iss though the price to rent
out the iss for eight days
only comes out to a total of 280
thousand dollars when you throw in the
cost of rocket launch
training and everything else involved in
sending tourists to space we get a final
price tag of 55 million dollars per seat
three about the individuals have already
booked the seats though
this includes larry connor mark pathy
and i think stibbey
ironically despite spending 165 million
collectively these men may not actually
be the first to rent out iss
you may have heard that tom cruise is
going to star in the first movie shawn
space
in september of 2020 it was announced
that tom cruise and director doug lyman
would be traveling to iss in october of
2021 to start filming
we haven't received any updates since
then though and it's very possible that
this mission will be pushed back into
2022.
when i said that the action group
wouldn't be the first rent out i
assessed though
i wasn't talking about tom cruise i was
actually talking about russia
you see when russia heard about the tom
cruise space movie
they decided that they had to shoot a
movie in space as well
russia plans to send their own actresses
space in october of 2021
to film a movie and i have a feeling
that russia
is much more dedicated in actually
achieving that time frame
but we'll just have to wait and see
anyway getting back to the axiom trip
though the tourists are free to just
relax and enjoy the trip they reveal
that they're looking to conduct a
plethora of experiments and educational
activities
so i guess it won't just be a leisure
after all
aside from sending tourists to the iss
with the help of spacex
axiom is looking to send tourists to
their own space station
at the start of 2020 action received a
contract from nasa worth up to 140
million dollars to build a commercial
module for the iss
the module is officially supposed to be
used for research and other applications
the module is meant for commercial use
though so maybe
it's meant for private research teams as
well as tourists interested in
conducting their own research
aside from this research module axiom is
also looking to add habitation and
tourist modules onto the iss
as well adding dedicated habitation and
tourist modules would complete the first
steps
in actually transitioning the iss into a
space hotel as opposed to simply being a
research facility that regular people
can visit
the first of these modules is expected
to be launched in the second half of
and axiom hopes to continue adding
modules throughout the second half of
the decade
eventually as axiom's additions to the
iss start to become too big
or nasa decides to de-orbit iss axiom is
looking to disconnect their modules from
the iss
and from their own commercial space
station this would be the first space
station dedicated to hosting private
tourists and researchers
action is not the only company looking
to capitalize on space tourism though
another company with even grander
visions is voyager
unlike the iss and the gym space station
which have components of research and
education
voyager is looking to build a space
station completely dedicated to
hospitality and tourism
and their design is literally straight
out of a sci-fi movie
first of all voyager is attempting to
simulate gravity which no other space
station has attempted to do
just like the movies warrior plans to
make a spinning station that will
basically pin tourists to the walls of
the station
the rotation is expected to simulate
one-sixth of earth's gravity
and all habitation and activity modules
will have the simulated gravity
voyager also understands that one of the
main reasons that people want to visit
space
is to experience weightlessness so they
have arranged a solution for this
as well whenever you're not sleeping or
chilling in one of their habitation
modules
you can take the elevator to the center
of the space station which will offer a
zero gravity experience
in terms of safety voyager plans to
incorporate 44 emergency return vehicles
into their space station which is
basically one for each habitation module
these emergency return vehicles vaguely
resemble nasa's space shuttle
and they will be capable of completing
an automated flight back to earth
as for amenities warriors looking to
match luxury hotels on earth
as much as possible their entry-level
hotel suite offers 30 square meters or
320 square feet of living space
these suites will support up to two
people and offer private bathrooms which
include both toilets
and showers if you want something bigger
you can spring for the luxury villas
which are absolutely massive
each villa is expected to have 500
square meters or 5
300 square feet of living space these
villas feature cooking facilities
three bathrooms and can support up to 16
people each
voyager is looking to provide a gym and
activity module as well
they claim that these modules will be 7
meters tall and support basketball
weightlifting and cardio i don't think
anyone visiting the space hotel
is looking to get a serious workout in
but it would be quite interesting to try
these tasks in an environment with one
sixth of gravity of earth
aside from a gym voyager is also looking
to offer a restaurant
and bar apparently the restaurant will
feature iconic ashdraft food
like freeze dried ice cream but they'll
also serve gourmet food that is
delivered to the station on a bi-weekly
basis
the entire station is expected to offer
a total of 11
600 square meters or 125 000 square feet
of habitable space this is enough to
support 280 guests and 112 crew members
considering the large capacity of the
station john blinkow the leader of the
effort
is hoping to bus customers in using
starships that's all great and all
but when will it open and how much will
it cost well
their goal is to open in 2027 so not
that far from now
but the ticket price is of course quite
high given the scope of the trip
right now a three and a half days day on
the voyager space station
is expected to cost five million dollars
per person and
that's not including the starship ticket
there and back now
it should be noted that visions like
this in the past have not exactly panned
out
orion span for instance pitched the idea
of building a small tourist space
station
in 2018 their vision was nowhere near as
grand as voyagers
but unfortunately they were unable to
raise enough money and they would end up
returning all the money they raised and
show another project
this isn't to say that voyager will fail
but simply the process of building a
space hotel is still extremely difficult
nonetheless with nasa opening up the iss
for space tourism
multiple companies working on space
hotels and rapid progress with starship
i think it's just a matter of time until
we see a full-on space hotel like
voyager and visions
will we see it in the 2020s probably not
but will we see it in the 2030s quite
possible
when do you guys think that we'll see
full on space hotels comment that down
below
also drop a like if you guys love to
stay in space hotel one day when the
tickets are cheaper
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you